just like that motherfucker's your uncle
Joey here representing life
I too will represent life we don't give
a [ __ ] about Martians or [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] these idiots are
talking about we're representing life we
live every day we sling dick I'm not
living in a [ __ ] fantasy computer I'm
out there [ __ ] both hands in there
digging you got to be on the front
[ __ ] lines you understand me you got
a walk you got to feel the heartbeat of
the [ __ ] ground that's how you
[ __ ] live your life I don't give a
[ __ ] about none of these [ __ ]
or what they got to do with my mom I had
me I came out of that [ __ ] with a
biblical cord and once they back that
off I was like Michael Jackson 279 solo
[ __ ] from the Garden of Good and Evil
reporting to you smoke no some sativa
this morning the man of many reefers a
little [ __ ] sour headband from
perennial always taking account of
[ __ ] Joey
I don't Sonny
snowing blizzards it's always a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
it's that [ __ ] fountain are you the
juice that's in your nutsack that keeps
your heart [ __ ] pumping and that
passion [ __ ] going [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] with their stupidity Trump
in there who gives a [ __ ] wake up grab
your [ __ ] you have a protein shake a
little steak and eggs like uncle Joey no
egg whites to eliminate the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and you go in there and [ __ ] first
and they can't stop you understand me
look at me I'm fat I'm ugly and I'm all
old I don't give a [ __ ] jack cuz when
they made me they broke the [ __ ] mold
the same way they broke the [ __ ] mold
when they made you some [ __ ]
can't be as asius
how many these [ __ ] people left hush
the Trump winners have live in the
country probably about you know why as
they just talked
that's a dip between these [ __ ]
and us we don't just talk me just sit
there in silence thinking went to
[ __ ] strike
you understand me cuz you don't know
when the [ __ ] is striking it's not gonna
work out for you
blade way enough with the [ __ ] listen
it's time to see the [ __ ] devil let's
do no [ __ ] this thing is empty we got
some pineapple [ __ ] cushion let's
take a whack of this and just in case
it's a tea we don't work because you
know me dumb I'm gonna sit even listen
save that [ __ ] for some [ __ ]
three-year-olds all right
go blue BMP while you're at it we were
from the horse who were hitting [ __ ]
hard
we go thousands ahead of hash and
[ __ ] reefer we're recharging the mind
the soul and the [ __ ] spirits up oh
[ __ ] yourself with that [ __ ] we're gonna
YC the [ __ ] why go to [ __ ] yard if
you're not gonna see the devil you
understand me
like this it's alright
I hate this [ __ ] I gotta look at this
[ __ ] tool but that I could put this
on a cartridge and [ __ ] bomb a
country with that [ __ ] thing that's
the classic oh Jesus - [ __ ] they [ __ ]
gave contra fish it the hospital isn't
carried Princess Leia you got to make a
comeback but it didn't work out isn't
the best part of my day getting to see
you guys on this [ __ ] thing we smoked
a little bit and I get to look at your
eyeballs and you get to look at my
[ __ ] eyeballs alright those are the
eyeballs of a professional right there
when people ask me for my resume I go
take a little [ __ ] better than that boy
that can see I can see [ __ ] anything
with that [ __ ] eyeball understand me
not the [ __ ] you see other [ __ ] the
creepy [ __ ] I love when you guys join me
lets me know [ __ ] a couple of us is
still alive and we got balls of debt
understand me
balls of [ __ ] debt 2017 is gonna be
your year as long as you don't die
you're gonna be all right you're swingin
dick you're out there every day
believing in one person you you're a fan
of yourself up all these of that I'm a
fan [ __ ] you I'm a fan of meat [ __ ] I
get up in the morning what do I gotta
[ __ ] do it make it happen cuz of the
[ __ ] with the rest of these [ __ ]
taken no jujitsu today I [ __ ] tried
to sweep a guy as big as me and my
[ __ ] I don't know what happened over
here nothing popped but
we'll do the day off on 53 and a [ __ ]
steroids to help me recuperate you
understand me there's my little [ __ ]
dipstick here like I said these are T
biz alright if you're tan you gotta
happen at the pallor on it so you could
tell your friend body you a smoker and
that's just the way it is all right
you're alive [ __ ] don't worry
about anybody else you rely whereby you
okay and my deepest darkest moments you
think I was worrying about it oh my god
this guy's performing that oh it's such
a great album they're in the studio
collaborator there's a [ __ ] as long as
you're [ __ ] collaborating that's all
that matters
and if you're like me you're
collaborating with death on a daily you
don't give a [ __ ]
let's do one more right or wrong let's
do one more
but the [ __ ] is family [ __ ] major
around for maybe that filter a [ __ ]
breath ready to go
at a protein shake
I got about 140 grams of protein in me
already with the steak and the eggs I
got about 90 grams the [ __ ]
carbohydrate some like 58 grams of fat
I'm fat enough and the lava Caudill due
to smoothing out the [ __ ] and then you
go to the bathroom it comes out like
olive lap drown the [ __ ] and blow it
up and that's it and that's that he's
got two days left in 2017 go out like a
[ __ ] soldier you understand you don't
want like a fan meet my friends in there
there's a [ __ ] about your Bo [ __ ] you
[ __ ] friends it's all about you 2017
is all about you the more Starbucks no
more listen closer [ __ ] let's let's
take a trip to Egypt and walk around
listen I want to get shot I'll go buy
crack somewhere [ __ ] dark okay
go [ __ ] yourself I'm staying right here
I'm working on myself I'm slinging
they come even want to slay my dick but
I did 2016 so they're ready if you're
not leaving and I was thinking like that
2017 I'm gonna swing the biggest [ __ ]
victim on the way listen yourself man
koala [ __ ] boots alright cuz they
ain't giving away no not there for free
nothing is free there's always a by the
way stay black
uncle Joey loves you eat somebody's
[ __ ] monkey today grab your ball
salute the flag make an allegiance to
yourself one nation under God
indivisible with liberty justice reefer
and a big dick for all I'll leave you
with that have a great day
don't let nobody [ __ ] with you and keep
guys Oh Isis is that on roller skates